professor Witte which is that whether or
not you think there's a version of human
rights that all of the major religions
can agree upon and how you would respond
to claims that ideas like if faith is
essential to freedom and a very
pronounced emphasis on the individual
right of conscience or specifically
Christian or specifically Protestant
claims and and maybe you could say that
you know every world religion has these
elements within itself but I mean what
if it didn't I mean how would you go
about addressing it put together a
declaration a world declaration of world
religions understandings of Human Rights
human responsibilities which tracks in
part the universal declaration of human
rights but also articulates the
foundations on which those human rights
claims rests and also the caveat sand
qualifications and understandings that
individual faith communities might want
to have about certain fundamental rights
that they agreed to but one of apply
locally in their own unique way so I
would start with that as a as an
interesting experiment with what have
representatives from the multiple axial
religions agreed to in this world
Parliament of Religions
a second place I would look is to look
at the ratification with or without
understandings and reservations and
declarations of the various
international conventions that have
emerged post the Universal Declaration
of Human Rights and you can punch up the
energy you can punch up the UN website
and this look at the 1966 covenants and
look at the various conventions and
declarations on rights of women on
rights of children on rights of
indigenous peoples on the UN Declaration
of religious intolerance and the like
and not only will you have nation states
that have articulated their ratification
with understanding reservation of
declaration but you increase the Canales
also find religious communities in
organized hierarchical bodies who have
signed on with with or without
understandings or individual groups
within religious denominations that have
signed on and what's interesting is if
you go through that exercise and look at
what these folks have agreed to there
are certain fundamental
that are that are non-narrative
non-dairy Keable that are non-negotiable
freedom I mean the four freedoms that
Roosevelt aquele 'td before the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights
seems to be something that a lot of
these religious communities embrace on
the strength of various canonical
formulations basic freedom to believe
basic freedom to act basic freedom of
want they get freedom from want basic
freedom for security
these become fundamentals that are
embraced universally if you look at a
variety of forms of literature that have
emerged in the last 15 years some of its
cited in a couple of footnotes in the
article that was assigned to you you can
see a whole bunch of books emerging now
about Asian religions and human rights
values African religions with human
rights values Western religious and
human rights values and there's a new
book edited by my wife's husband that's
coming out called religion and human
rights we just asked leading scholars in
each of the faith traditions around the
world to articulate what for them are
the non-negotiables six months from now
we'll have a good answer as to where the
overlap the consensus is across the
board